militärische spannungen und konflikte
sind auf europäischem boden
zurückgekehrt die rüstungsausgaben
steigen und das vertrauen zwischen
russland und dem westen ist insbesondere
seit der krise am tiefpunkt angelangt
eine neubelebung der rüstungskontrolle
könnte wieder für eine annäherung sorgen
heute in vechta kompakt konventionelle
rüstungskontrolle in europa was ist nun
rüstungskontrolle rüstungskontrolle
dient grundsätzlich dazu unsicherheiten
zu beseitigen die gefährdung durch
überraschungsangriffe einzudämmen
spannungen abzubauen und folglich mehr
sicherheit und stabilität zu erzielen
militärische informationsaustausch und
gegenseitige überprüfungen bilden das
rückgrat der rüstungskontrolle
dadurch sollen gefährlichen
fehleinschätzungen und misstrauen
vermieden werden
eine kurze rückschau schon bald nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg standen sich die usa
und die damalige sowjetunion feindlich
gegenüber europa geriet aufgrund seiner
geopolitischen lage ins zentrum der
spannungen zwischen den hochgerüsteten
supermächten militärische entspannung
war dringend nötig um eine eskalation zu
verhindern
15 jahre verhandelten die nato und
warschauer pakt staaten erfolglos erst
1990 einigen sie sich am rande der
konferenz für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa seit 1995 die
usd auf den vertrag über konventionelle
streitkräfte in europa den kse-vertrag
darin legten sie obergrenzen für
konventionelle waffensysteme und
stationierungen in bestimmten räumen
zwischen dem atlantik und dem oral fest
massenvernichtungswaffen samt raketen
waren davon nicht erfasst
für jede seite wurden folgende
höchstgrenzen beschlossen
20.000 kampfpanzer 30.000 gepanzerte
kampffahrzeuge 20.000 artillerie systeme
6800 kampfflugzeuge sowie 2000 angriffs
hubschrauber die osze um die in ihrem
nahbereich verhandelten
rüstungskontrolle
im laufe der zeit zu pfeilern
gesamteuropäischer stabilität
hervorzuheben sind als erster fehler
vertrauens und sicherheits bildende
maßnahmen wie zb jährliche militärische
informationsaustausch und gegenseitige
überprüfungen das 1990 erstmals
beschlossene wiener dokument ist dabei
von besonderer bedeutung
alle 57 osze staaten verpflichten sich
darin informationen über militärische
stärke bewaffnung und übungs aktivitäten
in europa auszutauschen
wegen der modernisierung der
streitkräfte wäre eine neuerliche
anpassung dringend erforderlich da
scheitert jedoch an den aktuellen
spannungen zwischen den nato-staaten und
russland der zweite pfeiler ist der
vertrag über den offenen himmel der 1992
von 34 staaten unterzeichnet wurde
dieser ermöglicht gemeinsame
beobachtungsflügen über dem territorium
der vertragsstaaten bei denen
militärische aktivitäten oder stationäre
nennt gefüllt werden dürfen
formal sind 92 bis ende 2017 erfolgten
mehr als 1400 flüge wegen ungelöster
probleme zwischen georgien und russland
wurden sie allerdings 2018 vorläufig
ausgesetzt
zum dritten pfeiler der schon erwähnte
kse-vertrag auch diese ist zentrale
element der konventionellen
rüstungskontrolle befindet sich in der
krise um die jahrtausendwende scheiterte
eine wegen der nato osterweiterung
erforderliche anpassung des vertrages
russland setzte 2007 die implementierung
auf unbestimmte zeit aus welche
initiativen gibt es zur wiederbelebung
der rüstungskontrolle deutschlands
damalige außenminister steinmeier hat
2016 bedauert dass über jahrzehnte
mühsam aufgebautes vertrauen dahin ist
gleichzeitig plädierte er für einen
neustart der konventionellen
rüstungskontrolle in europa diese sollte
unter anderem regionale obergrenzen
mindestabstände von größeren
kampfverbänden transparenz maßnahmen in
militärisch sensiblen zonen sowie neue
waffensysteme umfassen
schließlich verabschiedete die oecd ende
2016 die hamburger erklärung zur
rüstungskontrolle und der österreicher
spd-vorsitz 2017 und die enge außen und
militärpolitische abstimmung wurde die
struktur
dialog ein informeller austausch über
die zukunft der rüstungskontrolle ins
leben gerufen
ist es sinnvoll die rüstungskontrolle
wiederzubeleben von der absicht hier auf
jeden fall denn rüstungskontrolle
bewirkt vertrauensbildung
risikoreduktion und verhindert
rüstungswettlauf die zusammenarbeit von
staaten gerade auch zwischen
kontrahenten ist dabei entscheidend
durch die neubelebung der
rüstungskontrolle müsste den heutigen
verhältnissen entsprechen den die nato
osterweiterung 1999 und 2004 sowie die
annexion der queen 2014 haben die
geopolitische landschaft in europa
erheblich verändert auch im technischen
bereich gibt es viele neuerungen
so verwenden zum beispiel die meisten
armeen kampfdrohnen und marschflugkörper
diese müssten natürlich von
rüstungskontrolle maßnahmen erfasst
werden
wie kann es weitergehen auch wenn kein
schneller durchbruch zu erwarten ist
eine wiederbelebung der
rüstungskontrolle sollte versucht werden
denn ein neuerliches auflösen in europa
kann weder im westlichen noch im
russischen interesse seien gespräche
über bedrohungs wahrnehmungen oder den
möglichen inhalt neuer vereinbarungen
könnten mittelfristig wegbereiter für
militärische entspannung sein und
rüstungskontrolle könnte als weg aus der
sicherheitspolitischen sackgasse
verstanden und genutzt werden
die in wien ansässige oecd wäre die
geeignete plattform für diesbezügliche
gespräche
[Musik]